[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el
programa de france 24 en español en el
que analizamos todo el desarrollo de la
eurocopa de naciones y la copa américa
ya con las dos finales definidas estos
son los titulares
todo listo brasil y argentina se
enfrentan en la final de la copa américa
en un contexto poco atractivo para el
clásico sudamericano debido a la
pandemia y ahí el colchón aro lanzó su
predicción sobre el partido pero en la
ciudadanía existe poco interés por el
fútbol en los actuales momentos tenemos
informes de este brasil
por el podio las selecciones de perú y
colombia se enfrentan por el tercer
puesto en brasilia un duelo que recuerda
el partido por los cuartos de final de
la copa américa centenario en 2016 más
allá del resultado ambos seleccionadores
se han mostrado satisfechos con lo
alcanzado por su grupo
cuán blake se alista inglaterra italia
definirán al campeón de la euro 2020 el
domingo en londres el territorio
británico se muestra expectante por lo
que podría ser el primer triunfo de los
tres leones en un evento internacional
desde que alzaron la copa del mundo en
1966 tenemos reporte
como en cada una de nuestras emisiones
nos acompaña a sara castro directora del
diario hasta colombia bienvenidas ahora
como estas como siempre un gusto estar
con ustedes fácil de argentina dos de
los mayores rivales en el fútbol mundial
se miden para dirimir el campeón de la
presente edición de la copa américa será
la cuarta vez en la historia del torneo
que ambos se enfrenten en la final sobre
ello el presidente de brasilia y por
sonar o se refirió y además ofreció su
pronóstico del partido escuchemos
especialmente quiero decirle al
presidente de argentina que la única
rivalidad entre nosotros será el sábado
en el maracaná
[Música]
les diré el resultado de antemano 50
levantó la mano y digo 50
pero después de eso mi querido fernández
sepa que siempre queremos lo mejor para
nuestra unidad argentina y uruguay
para nuestro uruguay para paraguay para
mi hermano paraguayo marito y para que
otros países cercanos lo hagan bien
ahora sabemos que por sonar no se ha
mostrado fanático del fútbol y quizás su
apreciación está sustentada en eso en el
fanatismo pero que tiene brasil para
consolidar ese fanatismo frente a
argentina en el día de mañana
bueno pues afortunadamente bolsonaro no
es analista de deportes porque creo que
es un partido muy interesante y muy
complejo
yo creo que no hay un favoritismo a
pesar de que los antecedentes y la
historia darían como candidato a brasil
brasil ha jugado 34 partidos en el
maracaná 26 victorias 7 empates y apenas
una derrota esa de 1950 a que el
maracanazo
neymar nunca ha perdido en esa cancha
tite nunca ha perdido en suelo brasilero
es decir pero hoy bien lo decía cristo
en coros o un periodista de la nación y
es que las rachas son estos hasta que se
cortan y creo que este es el momento de
argentina y cuando hablamos de equipos
en este nivel creo que d
de situaciones de partido más que un
planteamiento en general
evidentemente en ambos equipos hay dudas
en brásil muchas menos porque tienen
viene un trabajo de mucho tiempo y la
principal duda es la ausencia de gabriel
jesús si vuelve a estar everton cebo
línea en esa posición o si tiene la
posibilidad firmino aunque ahora están
como un poco compartiendo el eje con
neymar por el lado de argentina hay
dudas en los laterales hay dudas en el
volante central e incluso en parte de
adelante pero lo que hemos visto además
es que scaloni le ha dado rotación a
varios de estos jugadores y todos
podrían tener un nivel aceptable
entonces creo que más allá de un
favoritismo
digamos exacerbado para alguno de los
equipos lo que vamos a tener es un
partido un partido interesante que
además del mundo del fútbol
pediatras una copa américa que empezó
con tantas dificultades
yo creo que ahí bolsonaro sierro en el
pronóstico para ese abultado 150 pero
hablemos de argentina argentina que
quizás no es peso el torneo de la mejor
manera pero se ha visto muy firme en los
últimos partidos que tiene que hacer
para contrarrestar a brasil
yo creo que intentar mantener la
intensidad durante los 90 minutos que es
lo que más le ha costado a este equipo
de escalón y escalón y tiene unos 15
primeros minutos muy intensos en donde
casi siempre se ayuda arriba en el
marcador es el periodo de tiempo en el
que más ha anotado goles pero no logra
mantener esa intensidad y ese dominio en
el juego evidentemente en este partido
haber dominios alternados pero necesitan
que es el momento en el que tengan la
pelota o que tengan la iniciativa ser
contundentes ayer decía claramente ti te
que con jugadores como neymar y messi
uno no puede neutralizar los básicamente
lo que hay que hacer es intentar
disminuir los o debilitar esos entornos
en los que ellos reciben el balón pero
más allá de eso creo que ambos equipos
tienen opciones y ambos equipos tienen
además a sus dos figuras con muchas
ganas de hacer
con muchas ganas de conseguir algo para
la selección hoy escuchaba en algún
podcast que ojalá los dioses del fútbol
por fin se acuerden de messi porque son
muchos años siendo el mejor sin este
título con la selección argentina
revisamos un poquito la historia de
estos dos equipos que se han enfrentado
en más de cien ocasiones a lo largo de
la historia entre ellos mundiales
eliminatorias a la copa del mundo
también en copa américa y juegos
amistosos el balance pero por muy pocos
partidos se está favoreciendo a brasil
conjunto que ha sacado mejores
resultados en tiempos recientes
hablábamos que en cuanto al torneo de
selecciones más antiguo del mundo ambos
equipos se han enfrentado en tres
ocasiones en una final la primera en
1937 que resultó favorable argentina las
dos últimas en 2004 y 2007 donde brasil
resultó vencedor pero más allá de ser
brasil y argentina- y además de jugarse
la final de la copa américa en la nación
y en específico en río de janeiro no se
percibe un ambiente de fiesta para
ampliar más sobre ello veamos el
siguiente reporte de nuestra
corresponsal
valeria con hembras y la copa américa no
ha despertado tantas pasiones como
podría esperarse y eso por una serie de
razones muchas personas no se sienten
identificadas con la canarinha con la
selección brasileña dicen que está muy
asociada a la cbf a la confederación
brasileña de fútbol acusada en los
últimos años de muchos casos de
corrupción también la forma en que la
copa américa fue invitada a brasil o fue
impuesta brasil ha creado muchas
suspicacias recordamos que ni argentina
ni colombia quisieron ser sedes por
causa de la pandemia y la decisión de
jair bolsonaro del presidente de traer
aquí la competición fue muy criticada
además la sensación que tengo es que en
las calles esos días los brasileños
están mucho más pendientes de la
eurocopa dicen algunos que hubo
demasiadas copa américas en los últimos
años y que eso también ha enfriado el
entusiasmo aún así una final entre
argentina y brasil es un clásico y es de
esperar que mucha gente asistan a esta
final porque no hay como no hacerlo
por otro lado en cuanto a la copa
américa las selecciones de perú y de
colombia se estarán enfrentando por el
tercer puesto esto el último lugar en el
podio ambos equipos han disputado 58
encuentros 17 de ellos por copa américa
donde el balance está favoreciendo a
perú
sara sabemos que ambos seleccionadores
ya se muestran satisfechos con lo
logrado pero cómo afrontar un partido de
esta magnitud un tercer puesto ayer
ambos entrenadores fueron muy generosos
con lo que significa competir por este
tercer lugar y ayer ya mencionábamos que
desde lo competitivo y desde estos
procesos que llevan ambos equipos ha
sido necesario y entre más unidades de
trabajo sumen es importante pero gareca
ayer mencionaba un punto que también es
importante y es el reconocimiento
monetario ambos equipos de asegurar un 6
millones de dólares por llegar hasta
este punto y el que gane va a sumar 4
más el que pierda 3 más y esto en el
contexto sudamericano es importante
porque si estamos hablando de que el
fútbol crezca también se necesita
inversión ojalá que estos ingresos que
llegan a las federaciones ha invertido
en lo que siempre hemos hablado
promover un desarrollo de juveniles muy
asociado a una idea de juego la idea de
lo que es estas elecciones quieren
representar creo que vamos a ver un
partido sin muchos cambios algunas
fichas seguramente que les van a dar
oportunidad a ambos entrenadores pero
son un partido que termina siendo de
competencia más allá del premio no de
esa medalla de bronce simbólica tiene
que ver con eso no con terminar una
etapa de trabajo que viene siendo muy
interesante para estos entrenadores
desde la fase de eliminatorias y ahora
en una copa américa que ha tenido
niveles muy parejos independientemente
de lo que ha demostrado brasil y
argentina pasamos a europa el próximo
domingo las selecciones de inglaterra e
italia disputará en el partido final de
la euro 2020
inglaterra regresa a una final de un
gran torneo desde 1966 pero conozcamos
los detalles que nos trae nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
está la euforia y la ilusión que se vive
en aquí en inglaterra que el público le
ha pedido al primer ministro que si la
selección inglesa ganar la eurocopa este
domingo cree un festivo nacional para
conmemorar esta hazaña se cuentan las
horas los minutos y los días para esta
final la primera desde 1966 cuando ganó
el mundial de fútbol generaciones
enteras han estado esperando este
momento las estadísticas favorecen a
italia pero lo cierto es que inglaterra
tiene un enorme punto a su favor y es
que será local con un estadio en su
mayoría vestido de blanco no se han
permitido el ingreso masivo de italianos
por las restricciones del cobi pero
habrá una excepción de mil italianos que
podrán ingresar al estadio de wembley
sólo podrán llegar al país el domingo y
salir de ese mismo día y deben
permanecer en una burbuja alejada de
todo el público en general el estadio de
wembley histórico por todo lo que
significa para el fútbol para la leyenda
del fútbol tendrá una capacidad de 65
mil
espectadores un 75 por ciento de su
capacidad total este evento ha sido
altamente criticado por un momento en el
que la variante delta del cobi está
disparada en el país y por lo que
significa que esta cantidad de personas
un evento masivo estén juntas sin
embargo este evento la eurocopa ha dado
un tipo de respiro ha sido un bálsamo en
medio de la crudeza y la tragedia que la
pandemia del cobi 19 ha significado para
este país
antes de despedirnos queremos
recordarles que el diario de copas
cambiará su horario este fin de semana
con motivo de la copa américa el
programa especial se realizará a las 21
40 horas de bogotá mientras que el
domingo el programa especial por la
final de la euro 2020 se llevará a cabo
a las 16 40 horas de bogotá los
esperamos
hasta aquí diario de copas por la tarde
de hoy continúen con más de la
programación de france 24 y france 24
puntocom